Spanish moss is neither Spanish nor Moss
buckle up for this one usually in a
situation like this we have like the
sort of scientific botany names to help
us out but the Latin name for this is
literally translates to resembling a
lichen like a lichen is like just Moss's
cousin but guess what it's not a lichen
either it turns out Spanish moss is a
flowering plant and it's in the same
family as pineapples it grows mostly in
the southeast United States and in South
America and it's actually a really dope
plant that makes these trees look
amazing it gets all its nutrients from
the air and from water doesn't even have
any Roots so why is it called Spanish
moss well the French French colonizers
they actually call that Spanish beard
for a while because it reminded them of
well the Beards of Spanish men but
honestly my favorite name is the one
that the indigenous Americans gave to
Spanish moss which was tree hair because